[Music]
thousands of people have died in care
homes in just a matter of weeks what we
thought wasn't gonna be that big and
then just literally within days weeks
just became massive as the government
prepared to save the NHS work care homes
left to fend for themselves I think from
the very start the government had good
intentions but the problem was those
intentions were not translated into
reality we investigate whether vital
protective equipment was diverted away
from care homes in favor of the NHS we
were told by one of our suppliers that
the NHS were taking priority and asked
why thousands of carers still haven't
had the tests they were promised we're
getting told that every staff member in
healthcare and every resident regardless
whether they've got symptoms or not will
be tested it's alive filmed over six
months we've witnessed the events
leading up to this crisis and we've seen
for ourselves what it was like at the
peak now big decisions are being made
about who should receive potentially
life-saving care and who shouldn't we're
the weak and the frail were left gasping
for air their families unable to say
goodbye I knew that promise John that
won't leave him on his own and I'd be
there for him and I couldn't and we've
taken what we've witnessed to the heart
of government I wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families of loved ones who died in care
homes because the government didn't
properly protect them
[Music]
[Music]
there are just over 20,000 care homes in
Britain offering a home to nearly half a
million elderly residents these are
private businesses separate from the NHS
but the to operate hand in hand
some care homes like this one play a big
part in easing pressure on hospitals
patients are transferred to places like
this when the NHS gets busy we naturally
become a nervous bill of the hospital
because when there's pressure in
hospital we see obviously patients
residents coming through our services we
really are an extension of the hospital
locally in the next few months these
beds will be in high demand in a way no
one could have predicted
[Applause]
brexit marks the end of one chapter but
a new ones just beginning coronavirus
orc Ovid 19 has reached the United
Kingdom and the government's trying to
contain it the care sector is left
wondering how all of this affects them
and they're told by the government that
it's business as usual in official
government guidance to the care sector
the advice couldn't be clearer there is
no need to do anything differently in
any care setting at present including
face masks face masks do not provide
protection from respiratory viruses and
overall risk to care homes it is
therefore very unlikely that anyone
receiving care in a care home or in the
community will become infected that
guidance remains in place until March
the 13th but by then the number of
confirmed kovat 19 cases has already
risen to 798 care homes are operating as
normal because they were told to I think
government guidance was slow we have not
had enough proper real-time data so when
the guidance was issued we would have
seen data that told us there were a
small number of infections by the time
the second set of guidance was issued
we'd be really clear about how serious
the pandemic was
[Music]
cheltenham becomes one of the last big
events to be held in britain and by now
the virus is already on its way to
killing tens of thousands of people care
providers have told me that during this
time staff absence levels went through
the roof
some people had symptoms and were self
isolating others I'm told were scared
stiff to come into work for fear of
getting the virus and so amongst all of
these staff shortages some workers
stepped in to fill the game hi Lisa how
are you doing
Lisa Flynn's mum iris Critchley was a
senior carer and a housekeeper in a care
home and had worked in care since
leaving school some of the stuff that
was showing symptoms or I had family
members show me symptoms so weren't able
to come in so my mum was the first one
there to offer a help and when we asked
her not to go
she said if everyone had the attitude
who would go and look after those people
I think was about the Tuesday she said
she'd got a scratchy throat we didn't
think anything of it because at the time
it wasn't one of the symptoms they got a
call I'm a mobile and it was my dad
saying I've had to call an ambulance
mom's not well and in the background she
shouted tell her all over that was
that's the last I've got off normal
within minutes
she'd closed her eyes and her lips were
going blue so he rang them back there
and they were talking him through the
CPR on the phone and it was too like
they tried there was nothing they could
do
[Music]
in Sheffield staff begin deep cleaning
the care home but no one really knows
what lies ahead we are gonna need
another extra staffing levels are low
and saw supplies of personal protective
equipment or PPE what should this
cupboard look like normally
well it sure was like full width with
them unsanitized and anti Tirith soaps
that moment we've not Adam delivered and
they said they were getting in in today
and we'll send him out as soon as they
come in and I've run them up this
morning to check and they didn't seem to
be any wiser when they were coming what
would happen if there was a couple of
cases here would make operating the home
quite difficult with new government
guidance is published on April a second
care homes are to play a big part in
protecting the NHS from being
overwhelmed in return the government
promises to help with supplies of
personal protective equipment and anyone
sent to a care home from hospital will
be tested for kovat nineteen first we
also need care homes to continue to make
their full capacity available to support
the national effort this means the NHS
will seek to discharge more patients
into care homes but supplies are PPE
promised by the government don't arrive
emails we've seen appear to show that
the NHS is getting priority from Monday
they cannot sell gloves face masks or
hand sanitizer to anyone apart from the
NHS
we will be out of stock for these for
the rest of the year as it stands we
find out late last week that these
gloves are going directly to any chest
and we have no control over this the
Department for Health and Social Care
told us that PPE supplies were
originally only meant for NHS trusts it
wasn't until April the 6th that the
government was able to supply care homes
by then people were dying concerns start
to grow many social care workers begin
to struggle to access tests which would
clarify whether they had the disease or
not and care providers have told us that
they begin to receive discharges from
hospital without the promised covent 19
tests and because hospitals don't have
to provide care homes with test results
for patients they discharge many homes
were left in the dark the advice was if
in doubt isolate the patient
it's called barrier nursing so bury
nursing is what we do when somebody has
got a virus we have to put things in
place we've got bins gloves masks aprons
hand-washing sanitizing we have to do
that for each and every Intuit
individual person and that is to prevent
the spread of the virus it is yeah yeah
but it's as only as good as that PPE
staffing absolutely if you've not got
the adequate PPE it won't work the
system will fail at that point care
homes are now fighting a virus with poor
supplies of PPE and in some cases no
idea who has the disease or not I think
it just come out I know we're really
what we thought wasn't going to be that
big and then just literally within days
weeks just became massive it just took
over a full floor of the unit of the
home and in a matter of days we just
fell you know where is it going to end
is this gonna wipe all residents out we
just you know we just have no idea what
we're up against to be honest
and so at the peak of the crisis we
decide to return to the home it is now a
place consumed by an invisible killer
and we're about to witness the effects
of that for ourselves
[Music]
it's the peak of the pandemic and the
death toll across the country is rising
we're back at the care home but it is
very different now there are so many
covered 19 cases that we have to wear
special protective clothing before we
can go inside
[Music]
coronavirus has ripped through these
wards with frightening pace in just two
weeks and they're dying here
the protective clothing the nurses wear
consists of a thin plastic apron a face
mask and some gloves it is all they have
room after room there's an elderly
resident fighting for each breath Laura
and Anne say they've accepted that they
can't help everyone feels horrific
knowing that we're not doing enough for
them and we're trying our best where you
was in everything that suggested for us
to use and it's not enough and that's
heartbreaking really yeah
we even got to our worst point the
number of people who are infected with
culvert 19 is rising by the day here and
there are severe staff shortages too
because like the residents the staff are
being infected now big decisions are
being made about who should receive
potentially life-saving care and who
shouldn't in one room a 76 year old man
called John Allison he's struggling to
breathe - they try to make him
comfortable but it's obvious that he's
not and he is deteriorating fast
John was a kind and caring loving
gentleman it was lots of fun
he loved walking around this part with
his wife and the walk around here most
days this favorite place to come we've
been in hospital and lost the use of his
legs so they discharged him for
rehabilitation cause John lives in the
first floor flat services we'll send him
into the care home can stop there for a
couple of weeks to build his strength up
I'm a bit of physio and at the same time
we developed OBE in 19
[Music]
John hasn't had anything to eat or drink
now for nearly two days Oh food and he
was absolutely petrified of Kovac and he
just kept saying I'm really scared I'm
gonna Gary I'm not washing my hands I'm
not able to keep myself clean spent most
of the night tossing and turning because
I knew that promised John that won't
leave him on his own and I'd be there
for him it's just heartbreaking not
being there with him not being there
when he took his final breaths
I still can't describe it from him being
absolutely fine to die in it we'll fight
him for his breath you were fighting he
couldn't it can't breathe it were awful
they were awful they were fighting the
only thing that we could do is sit there
be there to end it's hard to sit with
somebody knowing that you're not their
family but you've got to try and act
like their family and try and put
yourself in their shoes of how they're
feeling as they can't be with that
person
so I was happy that I could be in the
place of them just so they could know
that somebody was with him throughout
the pandemic the government has held
daily news conferences it's an
opportunity to put what we've witnessed
to the health secretary Matt Hancock
Nick Martin from Sky with my inbox is
anything to go by today the care sector
is watching this right now and is
desperate for you to tell them that they
will get regular tests so they can end
this lottery can you give that guarantee
to them yes I can Nick that is coming
and last week we were able to open up
testing to the to staff in care homes
and throughout this there's been the
availability of testing on a clinical
basis within care homes as you mentioned
and and this is an area of incredibly
high importance because precisely as
you've seen some of the most vulnerable
people live in care homes and especially
in nursing homes and therefore getting
this right is is just is so important
the Department for Health and Social
Care told us that capacity is available
for any care worker who needs a test but
the national care forum estimates that
just over 1/5 have managed to get one
we've been sent this email dated May the
7th that's three weeks after the Health
Secretary promised tests for all an
official from the Care Quality
Commission admits that not everyone is
getting tested there is not yet a
universal system in place at the moment
there isn't a service available although
I understand it was promised by
ministers some time ago Cali Hopkinson
runs a care home in Leeds she emailed me
after the Downing Street press briefing
19 of her residents died in two weeks
she says she didn't receive the PPE the
government promised and has struggled to
get tests she's joined by pearl Jackson
the home owner and who's been in the
care business for 40 years we're getting
told that every staff member in health
care and every resident regardless
whether they've got symptoms or not will
be tested it's allowed out of 62 staff
members that I've got three of them have
been tested three so for two week I had
no gloves and I had no masks delivered
I've even gone to a friend of mine who
owns a tire garage and he's given me
boxes of black gloves out of his star
room because we have known we've even
considered by Mary girls and some
sterilizing tablets we were getting that
desperate at one point in recent weeks
hospital admissions have begun to fall
but pearl told me about one resident who
was denied hospital treatment by doctors
she was gasping for air it was confirmed
by the paramedics and what appeared to
happen and I've got a note here that
from the manager it was rejected to take
her to hospital by a consultant
somewhere who didn't know her
and then he advised the paramedic to get
the GP on the ipod who could speak to
the person and say look you're gonna die
it's gonna be a matter of hours you're
not going to a hospital she pleaded with
them to take her to a hospital and the
family stood outside the window into the
evening and what she died is there any
way of justifying that I don't know no
they should be able to die with dignity
and that's the one thing that they got
deprived of dying with dignity as well
with no treatments no oxygen how can you
leave someone gasping for air during the
crisis the government reported a daily
death count but deaths and care homes
weren't included had they been the
growing death toll might have been
spotted sooner the tragedy for
government is that they didn't have
enough real-time statistics if we'd had
a similar approach to stats in social
care we'd have known what we were
dealing with much sooner you knew and
your department knew that this was a
high-risk area
you give you've issued guidance to care
homes repeatedly over the last few
months I wonder if you will take this
opportunity to apologize to those
families of loved ones who died in care
homes because the government didn't
properly protect them that's the thing
is Nick I think that's I think that's
unreasonable as a question actually
making sure that care homes have the
support they need has been absolutely at
front of mind right from the start
especially because people are more frail
and therefore they're more at risks
the elderly have paid a high price in
this pandemic a staggering 40% of all
kovat 19 deaths have been in care homes
and the numbers are still rising the
health secretary said the care sector
was a priority and had always been the
priority my personal opinion and
experience it hasn't been I think carers
are the unforgotten heroes in all of
this and she was a hero
she put a life at risk every day going
to work and sadly she lost her life
through that how can you shield a nation
of the vulnerable if you're not gonna
shield the most vulnerable patients are
being sent in all the time from hospital
patients carrying a deadly virus we have
to be the voice of the elderly
generation if we don't speak up no one
will know what's happened you know I I I
almost said at one point it's it's like
they're a sacrifice am I wrong I don't
know
[Music]
you
[Music]